-Finish him! *dramatic music* When Daniel San hit that crane kick we learned to never give up.
When Lloyd Doppler lifted his boom box we learned love is patient
And when Johnnie and Baby danced we learned how to come out of our shells
There's something magical about the movies we watched in our youth
those moments that helped shape our budding personalities
Like when Ferris Bueller taught us
-You can never go too far.  Jack Burton taught us... -It's all in the reflexes.
And the Ghostbusters taught us  -when someone asks you if you're a god you say yes
As we get older though
This magic fades.
Dampened by our age, experience, and cynicism these days we bring so much with us into the theater it's a miracle we enjoy anything at all.
But we can have that sense of wonder again. And the answer isn't in bigger special effects, sequels, or reboots.
In in characters we care about doing things that excite or inspire us
Like when Luke learns who his father is.
When Elliott learns how to say goodbye
And Dee learns to never get on the freeway
The answer is also in us. Let's make movies magic again. Let's turn off our phones and our cynicism.
Let's ignore reviews, hype, gossip, and snark
And just enjoy the show, like when we were younger and George McFly taught us how to stand up for ourselves.
The Goonies taught us to never say die.
And PeeWee taught us there's no basement at the Alamo. -There's no basement at the Alamo. *laughs*
Movies can still teach us a lot about ourselves. We just have to be willing to learn. -Come back tomorrow
*Dramatic Music*